how do
you handle the academy awards at this
time
are you going there do you ignore it
just call it out what
i think you know there's like definitely
like pressure in one way to be like and
this is this is a vacation let people
forget we just want to have this night
but it's like well we have so many eyes
and ears on this show i think it's a
great opportunity
to
you know at least comment on a couple
things so i have
i have some some jokes that um
that kind of highlight
the the sort of
current condition i mean there's so many
there's so many awful things happening
that it's like it seems hard to focus on
which which one
um you know but i actually pitched i was
like i
i wanted to
find a way to have zielinski like
you know
satellite in or make a tape or something
and just because it just because so many
eyes get on there's so many eyes on the
oscars that
um
but you know i'm not afraid to go there
uh but you know i it's not it's it's not
me producing the oscars that's why i
love you
[Music]